what untradable Drophead sneaking up
III literally thought that one of the
snakes got glitched for some reason what
is the kill account let's see what's the
kill account 403 what the hell
metamorphosis I never saw that before I
because I don't use pets at all I had it
on my solo account before but first time
I see something like this okay so um I
guess I need to ensure it like right now
no I'm still gonna do like a few more
kills I'm not gonna waste this trip oh
by the way whenever they killed is all
that I people say that I'll leave some
so under the teleports on the floor
these are different you cannot pick
these up
okay got nothing from this to but let's
teleport in my house I want to show you
something so previously you know as I
was using my heart I boosted my magic
level but if I went into white portal it
would always add he said it and I
couldn't you know I couldn't invigorate
the heart again cuz it would be uncool
down so I would have to kill Zelda
without getting any magical boost but
with this pool again this pool is just
so amazing I can drink it and it doesn't
decrease anything you just said restores
all my stands back okay let's go to
insurance let's use the Zelda pet on
this guy 500k a yes please now to be
honest when I think about it let's check
let's check let's how how many pets do I
am well not that many I thought I had a
little bit more I don't know I don't
want to say this but I probably have the
most pets as a hard cut iron man but I
don't think that information was at the
least publicly so I can't really say but
I have like five pets which isn't too
much but I have these three very rare
pets triada as a hardcore Ironman better
yet to get Tanglewood at the time when I
got it only six people had it well six
hardcore Ironman and then there is
Phoenix pet which I think a lot of
hardcore Ironman have it but it's like 1
in 5,000 drop date so I would say these
today are very rare these two are like
especially a Rocky I think a lot of
people have it it's like if you're going
for 99 thieving you're probably gonna
have it
and I don't have a dad pet which I would
say it's one of the more common modes
and also Scott is our pet I don't have
that either so you know the doors are
pretty open to receive more pets but I
don't know what's up with this luck
every single pet that I got my kill
count is complete - like 400 at Zelda
like 30 at getting Cleora got like 90 on
Phoenix 6 on tap no no I guess I did
harvest like a lot of the low level
crops like herbs and all that and I
didn't receive it but it was like second
magic 3 or something you know it's it's
very lucky Araki as well at like 70
thieving or something and then sneaking
it like 400 is what the hell is
happening you know why am I so lucky in
these things where is my dragon one
hammered Jagex
anyway you may be wondering why I was
killing Zelda I was running out of
charges on my blowpipe I'm so quite low
I'm 21% and I want to do a little bit of
the dates with teams because let me show
you something like I don't want to spoil
too much if you're watching iodine
devious but this guy like he did what
like 28 kill account he did away mod so
I'm not gonna spoil over what what he
got there's something by look at the Cal
come from 28 to 20 it's like every five
it aids one of the teammates get
something and it's like but I guess it's
like six people so there is like a low
chance that you're gonna get something
but this guy just sees loot all the time
and I'm kind of look at this like 32
Ford kill account another guy received
something it's like back to back you
know it's I kind of want to do it aged a
little bit not solo but with teams the
kill counts are also very fast what is
this like 33 minutes you know I want to
do this I wanna go to AIDS but I cannot
do it with 22 charges on my blowpipe
hello today's gonna be a very chilled
day for me because I'm just gonna relax
I think right now and I'm gonna go ahead
and cook some calm ones what I don't
really like about them is like a look at
monkfish whenever they go to cook it and
has cooked all right but if you cook on
them once it doesn't have it you have to
go make it what he says make Ickx or
order said cook it it says make eggs it
doesn't even say cook okay whatever
so I'm gonna go ahead and cook my
six point four K that I caught it seems
that I have to say hello again because
for me it's been one day now since I've
started cooking these kind of ones but
here we are a 9,000 of them in total and
apparently they went back up in price
eight point three million worth all nine
thousand I don't even know what's the
deal price uh now how much is this I was
buddy says it's pretty much the same but
cooked one is way over so if you want to
make money if you're like very new play
like look it's 921 according to always
buddy so you're making like 400 K per
one k cooked like I mean but I think
they born until 99 cooking oh yes and I
totally forgot to show you my cooking
experience so Colonel level is nily
salmon and I am only 300 K experience
away from 98 so a game like 1.4 mil XP
cuz I think I started at like 10 ml
cooking so it's going pretty well I do
have a lot of grapes but I don't know if
I should be using them you know I should
just dedicate one full day collecting
supplies like mushrooms and snape grass
or all that kind of stuff just to have a
few thousand each so I'm pretty much set
for months and I don't have to do this
again it would be pretty cool looking in
the bank as well don't even know what's
the optimal way to do this I know I
should be equipping this to save
inventory space but I just cannot see
how many mushrooms I have if I do like
this it's like how many do I have you
know you constantly have to go to your
inventory in just one space don't care
too much about that you know what I just
realized is that whenever be casting
this bloom spell on the sickle you lose
some player points so it's four to one
at the moment if I cast this one goes
down to 39 so you need to recharge and
previously I would go to clan wars to do
that but now look this is a rejuvenation
pool and instantly there is a fading
it's just so convenient it's right there
okay know what this is going way too
fast I want to see how long one trip
takes to do this so from the moment i
teleport to my house let's start the
time at teleport and let's see it should
be under one minute yeah is EV not under
one minute if I click how so 54 seconds
or so to do one full trip and this
should be my last one okay so this is
definitely the last trip I go like 500
of the
actually but I was thinking about this
what the hell look okay so one our word
has 60 minutes okay and if you time this
by 26 this is how many mushrooms I
collect per a minute so it's a thousand
five hundred mushrooms an hour okay now
look at this one mushroom is 786 GP ped
and this is what OS body is telling me
so if we time this seven eight six are
you telling me that collecting mushrooms
at the moment is 1.2 million GP an hour
I'm sorry I don't remember these kind of
rates previously I mean I do have the
best things to like get there cuz I just
realized that the pool in your house it
really helps a lot because otherwise how
you gonna recharge it I guess you could
just build an altar in your house one
more potion here we go 84 hell-blood can
I make anything from this one upgrade
and oh I don't need to boost anymore if
I want to upgrade them but I don't think
I have any lava scales at the moment I
know that I got some of them when I was
fishing the lava eels but here I don't
have them how many extended I did anti
anti fired only 92 and I don't have any
more scales so do people even use these
the kinda I guess it e useful in certain
situations but it feels like Y just not
use this one okay also something that I
real want to talk about is kind of
serious it's about my youtube channel if
you notice for the past one month
I think it's been happening I've been
very inconsistently uploading like every
three or four days and my schedule for
the past five years was a video every
two days and I've been sticking to it so
nicely like I would almost not forgive
myself if I had to if I skipped a day if
I uploaded three days instead of two
days but now it seems like a regular
thing for me to do so what I want to say
about this is that currently on my
hardcore either man I am at a stage
where everything is very slow like if I
want to get 102 levels it's gonna take
ages to level up and there is not that
much footage that I can get from it if
I'm training hair blood it's like I
pretty much have to today in two levels
of hair blood without even showing
anything is that it's like nothing too
show so I have to get it off video just
get it but it takes so much time and
just you have to understand even PVM I
go to Bandos do like 200 kills if I
don't get anything there's literally no
footage it's like a gamble
am I gonna upload a video tomorrow or
than five days if I don't get anything
that I'm not gonna be uploading anything
so really I don't know if it's gonna
change I think my new schedule is gonna
be a video every three days I think four
days is a little bit too long but a
video a 10-minute video like a pretty
long one every three days it's I don't
want to say that it's gonna be my
schedule from now on but temporarily at
least unless something happens like a
new update maybe like a new item in mode
which is gonna be like crazy like group
item and though I don't think I don't
think I wanna abandon this account but
if if a lot of people want me to try a
new game mode if it's gonna be out you
know a lot of people are talking about
like ultimate hardcore Ottoman by the
way I'm not gonna be playing that not I
I want Bank you know I wanna I wanna see
my bank I want to collect stuff I want
to get like triple Bandos chestplate and
I will just I want to put it in my bank
if you're an ultimate and you get like
9th assets before they get a hilt like
where are those ninth assets going you
know there's nothing to show it's just
it's it's gone whatever
yeah just severely dislike the current
situation like I want to upload
something but I just can't
and then I upload some bad video which
I'm not even proud of but I have to cuz
it's like well times up three days it's
been three days even though that was not
enough time to do it